MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY IS BACK IN
SESSION I WILL ASK ALL ABSENT
MEMBERS TO PLEASE RETURN TO THE
CHAMBERS
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE CHAMBERS
AND TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR OUR
SPECIAL SESSION
MEMBERS TO THE FLOOR AND TAKE
YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
CHAMBERS.
CHAMBERS
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
CHAMBERS MEMBERS AND GUESTS MAY
BE SEATED
THE ASSEMBLY IS BACK IN SESSION
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE BE
SEATED.
WE WILL RECESS THE REGULAR
SESSION AND CONVENE THE JOINT
CONVENTION.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE
ASSOCIATE JUSTICES ARE IN THE
CHAMBER.
I AM APPOINTING A JOINT
COMMITTEE ON ESCORT TO GREET THE
CHIEF JUSTICES AND THE ASSOCIATE
JUSTICES.
THE ESCORTS SHOULD RETIRED THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AS I CALL
YOUR NAMES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
COOPER.
BAKER.
CUNNINGHAM.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KALRA.
RAY S..
AND STONE.
SENATORS.
BATES.
HERNANDEZ.
JACKSON.
LARA.
MITCHELL.
AND MONEY.
PLEASE PRETTY PLEASE BRING THE
CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE ASSOCIATE
JUSTICES TO THE ROSTRUM
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
WE HAVE SEVERAL HONORED GUESTS
TODAY.
PLEASE WELCOME THE FAMILY OF THE
CHIEF JUSTICE HER HUSBAND MARK
AND HER EXTENDED FAMILY. PLEASE
STAND HERE RECOGNIZED
.
WE ALSO HAVE ONE OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS HERE
PLEASE WELCOME THE ISSUE
INSURANCE CAN.
THE HONORABLE DAVE.
WE ALSO WELCOME THE OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND GUESTS
THE LEGAL COMMUNITY.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THOSE
PRESENT TO THE BENCH BAR
COALITIONS.
IT IS NOW MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THE HONORABLE KEVIN DALY ON.
WHO WERE MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES?
SO WE AS WELL AS A SENATE'S.
MY FRIEND MY COLLEAGUE.
THE GROUP ASSEMBLY.
BAKER AT THE UN DON'T THINK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HOSTING THIS.
HERE
CREDIBLE ONE FOR.
AND I WANT WELCOME ALL OF OUR
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS FAMILY AS
WELL AS FRENCH.
COLLEAGUES.
AN INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY IS
CRITICAL OF PRESERVING A FREE.
AND DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY.
PROTECTIVE FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
COURTS IS MORE IMPORTANT EVER.
THOSE IN THE EXECUTIVE AND
LEGISLATIVE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT FAILED TO RESPECT THE
COURTS.
IN HONOR JUDICIAL DECISIONS DO A
GREAT DISSERVICE.
TO OUR NATION.
WITHOUT A FULLY FUNCTIONING AND
INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY. OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT IS
THREATENS.
FORMER ASSOCIATE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR
REMINDED US BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT.
THAT JUDICIAL INDEPENDENCE IS
HARD
CREATE YET EASIER THAN MOST
PEOPLE IMAGINE.
TO DESTROY.
WITH THAT IT'S A GREAT PLEASURE
FOR ME TO INTRODUCE.
OUR SOCIAL INJUSTICES.
MEAN CHEN. MEAN CHAIR.
CAROL KOREAN CAROL CALLING.
GOODWIN LIU
AND WHEN LOSE.
YOUNGER KRUGER YONDER.
AND HE'S NOT WITH US TODAY BUT I
WANT TO RECORD AS MUCH GENERAL
FOR THEM YOU KNOW QUITE YET WAS
NOT WITH US TODAY AND LAST BUT.
COLLEAGUES.
IT IS MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE OUR
CHIEF JUSTICE OF CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT.
THE AUDIBLE TINY CONCEALED
SOCKET WE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU SPEAKER RENDON.
PRO TEM DELEON FOR INVITE.
JOINT SET
THE LATEST.
HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FOR.
IDEAS COME.
ATTORNEYS LAWYERS STATE.
ALSO OF COURSE LEGAL COMMUTE.
IT HERE TODAY AND VISITED
LEGISLATIVE.
THERE.
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL THAT SOME OF
MY BELOVED FAMILY IS HERE
TONIGHT.
STATED BY HAS
AND MARK
AND MY IN LAWS JEROEN DOROTHY.
THE FIRST TIME MY MOTHER MARY
CANTILENA NAY.
BUT I ALSO HEARD THE YOU TO
VIDEO AND THE TWO WEEKS LATER I
LOVE YOU MOM.
BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO REFLECT AND TO GIVE
THINGS.
ALL THAT WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED TO
GATHER.
AS I OBSERVE THE HARSH RHETORIC
ON THE NATIONAL
STAGE I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEADERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA OF OUR
THREE BROWN.
GOVERNMENT
AND OUR CONSCIOUS ABILITY AS WE
NAVIGATED THE GREAT RECESSION
AND BEYOND.
IT IS TRUE WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE
CHALLENGES
BUT CALIFORNIA SURVIVES AND
THRIVES. BECAUSE OF OUR
COLLECTIVE WISDOM I'VE
UNWAVERING WILL AND OUR MUTUAL
COMMITMENT TO THE RULE OF LAW.
IT HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN EASY.
BEFORE YOU RENEWED INVESTMENT IN
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH.
DURING THE BUDGET CRUNCH YEARS.
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WAS
REFORMED.
AND ADDITIONAL WORK FELL UPON
THE COURTS TO ABSORB BROUGHT BY
THOSE CHANGES.
IT WAS DURING THE BUDGET CRUNCH
YEARS THAT THOSE REFORMS UNWOUND
DECADES OF LAWS PASSED BY
PREVIOUS LEGISLATURE'S AND
SIGNED BY PREVIOUS GOVERNOR.
IT WAS DURING THOSE BUDGET
CRUNCH YEARS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PRIORITIES AND POLICIES CHANGED
AND THE COURTS WERE TASKED WITH
INTERPRETING AND IMPLEMENTING
THOSE CHANGES AND WE DID SO FOR
EXAMPLE. BY PROCESS SEEN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF NEW
FILINGS FOR RE SENTENCED.
AND THIS WAS AFFECTED AND
CONTINUES TO AFFECT EVERY LEVEL
OF COURT AND AS YOU KNOW WE USE
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES AND
FOCUSED IN ON CRIMINAL MATTERS.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE STATUTES
MANDATE THAT FOCUS BUT BECAUSE
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTIES WERE AT
STAKE.
AND NOW YEARS LATER AFTER
RENEWED INVESTMENT IN THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH THANKS TO YOU
AND THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR.
WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STEP BACK AND STUDY.
THE NEEDS OF OUR COURT USERS AND
THE FUTURE OF JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE FIRST TURNED TO THE NEEDS
OF THOSE COURT USERS WHO ARE
INDIGENT AND ACCUSED.
AND IT IS IN THAT SITUATION WE
ASKED.
IS MONEY BAIL SAFE AND IS IT
EVEN FAIR.
AND SO THE ANSWER LIES IN OUR
PRE TRIAL DETENTION REPORT.
A REPORT THAT HAS THE ECHOES OF
HISTORY FROM NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
WHEN THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROBERT F. KENNEDY GAVE
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY.
AND HE SAID ABOUT THE MAKE ABOUT
THE MONEY BILL SYSTEM THEN.
THAT IT IS A VEHICLE. FOR
SYSTEMATIC INJUSTICE
AND HE SAID.
IT IS CRUEL AND THE COST
A BACK SYSTEM IS NEEDLESS
NO I'M GONNA TELL YOU IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR THAT WAS
PRETTY STRONG LANGUAGE.
AND I WILL SUBMIT TO YOU THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IT IS A
CLARION CALL FOR JUSTICE.
LET ME.
OR REPORT WAS DELIVERED BY IN
INTENTIONALLY SELECTED DIVERSE
GROUP.
JUDGES AND THE SEA
OH AND BY DIVERSE I MEAN MEN AND
WOMEN
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
JUDGE WITH MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE JUDGES WITH ONLY A
FEW.
I JUDGES WHO CAME FROM RURAL AND
URBAN COUNTY
AND JUDGES WHO CAME FROM SMALL
AND LARGE COUNT.
WE HAD A JUDGE ON THIS WORK
GROUP WAS A FORMER DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
WE HAVE A JUDGE ON THIS
WORKGROUP WAS A FORMER DEPUTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER. WE HEADED JUDGE
ON THIS WORKGROUP WHO WAS A
FORMER COP.
NOW I SMILE BECAUSE IT APPEARS
TO BE A RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
EXCEPT THAT I HAVE FAITH AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE FAITH. IN THE
DEDICATED PROFESSIONALS MEN AND
WOMEN IN OUR BRANCH
WHO WITH ARE SCARED DNA. WILL
DELIBERATE IN A FAIR AND JUST
MANNER.
AND I'M TOLD THAT THE FIRST
MEETING THIS GROUP AGREED ON
THAT THING.
BUT AFTER YEARS WORTH OF STUDY.
AND PUBLIC MEETINGS I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT THEY DELIVERED A
UNANIMOUS REPORT WITH TEN
RECOMMENDATIONS.
TEN RECOMMENDATIONS TAKEN AS A
WHOLE NOT PARKS REFLECT AFFAIR
SAFE OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
NOW AFTER THE MAIL STUDY WE
TURNED TO THE FUTURE OF JUSTICE
IN CALIFORNIA AND I FORM THE
FUTURE.
IT CONSISTED OF COURT USERS
COURT EMPLOYEES LAWYERS JUDGES.
AND I ASK THEM TO QUESTION THE
PAST PRESENT AND FUTURE AND TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW WE
GO FORWARD IN THE FUTURE WITH
JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AT THE TIME WE WERE
CONCERNED WITH TWO MAJOR FORCES.
THE FIRST WAS ANY INCOME
INEQUALITY. BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT
AT THE TIME AND THE BRANCH WAS
LOSING RESOURCES INCOME
INEQUALITY IN CALIFORNIA WAS ON
THE RISE.
IN FACT THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA REPORTS.
THAT OF THE POOREST CALIFORNIANS
THEIR INCOMES DROPPED BY NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
AND THOSE INCOMES HAVE NOT
RECOVERED SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION.
THE OTHER MAJOR FORCE WE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT IN THE FUTURES
COMMISSION WAS WHAT TO DO AND
HOW TO APPROACH. THE PROFILE OF
THE NEW PORT USER.
SO IN TODAY'S DAY AND AGE WHEN
ONLINE YOU CAN ORDER GROCERIES
AND YOUR DINNER WITHIN HOURS TO
YOUR DOORSTEP.
AND NGUYEN RETAIL AND
ENTERTAINMENT IS ON DEMAND AND
WE HAVE A TWENTY FOUR HOUR NEWS
CYCLE.
HOW DO WE PROVIDE ACCESS IN
FAIRNESS TO GENERATION Z.?
WELL THE FUTURES COMMISSION WITH
SIXTY FOUR MEMBERS STRONG. LED
BY THE INDOMITABLE DUO OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CHARACTER
OREGON AND NOW RETIRED JUSTICE
BILL MCGINNIS FROM THE
APPELLATE.
DISTRICT FIRST D. C. A..
WITH SIXTY FOUR MEMBERS STRONG
TWO YEARS OF VOLUNTEER WORK
DELIVERED POTHOLE SOBRE ARENA
INNOVATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND I AM GRATIFIED THAT THE
GOVERNOR STRONG PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
REFERENCES THREE OF THOSE
FUTURES RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
FIRST IS.
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPAND SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS SERVICES FOR THOSE WHO
COME TO COURT WITHOUT AN
ATTORNEY.
IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT OVER
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS COME
TO COURT WITHOUT AN ATTORNEY.
AND WE KNOW THAT. IN CIVIL CASES
IN THREE QUARTERS OF CIVIL CASES
AT LEAST ONE SIDE DOESN'T HAVE
AN ATTORNEY.
AND OUR SELF HELP PROGRAM SERVES
AT LEAST A MILLION PEOPLE A
YEAR.
AND ARE SELF HELP WEBSITE
RECEIVES FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION UNIQUE VISITS EVERY
YEAR.
SO THE NEED FOR SELF HELP IS
REALLY UNDENIABLE.
AND SECOND THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
AND WE SUPPORT THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION FOR OUR EFFORTS TO
INITIATE A TECH BASED TRAFFIC
SYSTEM.
IN FACT ONE THAT COULD LEAD TO A
CRACK DECRIMINALIZING MINOR
TRAFFIC IN
TIONS
AND MAKING LIFE SIMPLER FOR
EVERYONE. BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
GONNA PAY THAT TICKET ANYWAY YOU
MIGHT AS WELL DO IT ONLINE.
AND THIRD THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
AND WE SUPPORT FOR MILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS IN CIVIL
MATTERS.
NOW THE BAIL STUDY.
THE BILL STEADY AND THE FUTURES
RECOMMENDATION ARE FORWARD
LOOKING.
WHAT'S ESPECIALLY FORWARD
LOOKING IS ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BY.
FOR THE TRIAL COURTS.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE TRIAL
COURT'S THE NEEDED FLEXIBILITY
TO RESTORE SERVICES THEY
REGRETTABLY REDUCE.
FEW OF US NEED TO BE REMINDED
THAT IN THE GREAT RECESSION
CIVIL CASES TOOK A BACKSEAT TO
CRIMINAL CASES.
AND FOR MANY COURTS CIVIL
DOCKETS WERE AND CONTINUE TO BE
GREATLY DELAY.
AND SO THIS ADDITIONAL MONEY
WOULD HELP COURTS HELP THOSE WHO
WERE UNFORTUNATELY LEFT BEHIND
THOSE SEEKING CIVIL JUSTICE.
AND AS YOU KNOW CIVIL JUSTICE
ENCOMPASSES WIDE AND COMPLICATED
BODIES OF LAW MIGHT CONSTITUTE
CHAU LAW AND ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
AND CONSUMER LAW. AND HEALTH AND
WELFARE ACROSS THE BOARD AND IT
FOCUSES ON PLANES IN PERSONAL
INJURY CLAIMS FOR DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION MISCONDUCT LOST
JOBS.
AND MANY MANY MORE. AND WHO WAS
LEFT BEHIND WILL CHILDREN AND
ELDERS VETERANS BUSINESSES OUR
NEIGHBORS YOUR RELATIVES ARE
CONSTITUENTS WERE LEFT BEHIND.
AND I KNOW THAT EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM IS COMMITTED TO PROVIDING A
TIMELY AND FAIR ACCESSIBLE DAY
IN COURT FOR ARKANSAS
SHE WENT.
AND THIS MONEY WILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR COURTS TO HELP
AND HAVE AND RESOLVE CASES IN A
TIMELY MANNER IN THE CIVIL
ARENA.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WHAT WE KNOW.
IS THERE AN ONSLAUGHT OF CASES
WAITING TO BE FILED.
WITH THE FIRES ALONE WERE
INFORMED THAT ARE RESIDENTS OF
FILED MORE THAN FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND INSURANCE CLAIMS.
TOTALLY MORE THAN TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS CONCERNING THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND HOMES AND FOUR THOUSAND
BUSINESSES.
AND SO KNOWING THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE HAD A
HISTORICAL DELAY IN OUR CIVIL
JUSTICE ARENA. AND IN THE
ANTICIPATION OF NEW CASES.
I THINK IT'S ONLY TIME IT'S
REALLY FAIR AT THIS POINT.
TO ANNOUNCE IN FOCUS ON A THREE
TIERED CIVIL JUSTICE REFORM
INITIATIVE.
AND THE FIRST YEAR OF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE REFORM INITIATIVE SHOULD
BE THAT WE RESTORE COURTHOUSES
TO THEIR FULL OPERATING HOURS IN
STAFF.
THAT WE PROVIDE FAIR
COMPENSATION TO OUR CORE FAN.
AND ALSO AT THE SECOND PART OF
THIS TWO YEAR.
I SUGGEST THAT WE EMBRACE THE
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WHICH IS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS.
TECHNOLOGY IN TRAFFIC. AND
LANGUAGE ACCESS.
AND THIRD I THINK WE SHOULD WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO DEVELOP AN
EMPLOYEE A GROUP OF PEOPLE
CALLED FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM
LEGAL WAY FINDERS WHO COULD
PERSONALLY ASSIST PEOPLE WHO
COME TO COURT WITHOUT AN
ATTORNEY.
WE KNOW THAT WE COULD WORK
TOGETHER AND ALSO FIND BEST
PRACTICES AND DRAW ON THE WORK
OF OUR SELF HELP PROGRAMS AND
ARE EXCELLENT VOLUNTEER JUSTICE
CORE FOLKS WHO ARE USE NOW IN
LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO AND THE
BAY AREA.
SO WHAT COULD LEGAL WAY FINDERS
DO. WELL LEGAL WAY FINDERS CAN
MEET PEOPLE AND GUIDED THEM TO
THE APPROPRIATE WINDOW
APPROPRIATE ROOM COURT ROOM
APPROPRIATE COURTHOUSE.
A LEGAL WAY FINDER COULD EXPLAIN
THE OPTIONS AND THE CONSEQUENCES
AND THE PROCEDURES AND FIND THE
RIGHT FORUM AND ACTUALLY HELP
THE PERSON FILL OUT THE FORM AND
GET IT FILED IN THE RIGHT PLACE.
LEGAL WAY FINDER COULD PROVIDE
REFERRALS FOR SERVICES NOT ONLY
IN THE COURTROOM BUT OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY.
A LEGAL WAY FIND A COULD DO THIS
ON A ONE ON ONE BASIS OR IN A
WORKSHOP SETTING.
AND WE HAVE EXAMPLES FROM WHICH
TO DRAW FOR EXAMPLE A JUSTICE
CORPS VOLUNTEER THE DAUGHTER OF
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS TELLS US THAT
IN HER JOB.
SHE HELPS WOMEN IN HER COMMUNITY
OBTAIN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND SHE HELPS
TENANTS WHO ARE NEAR EVICTION.
A SELF HELP ATTORNEY IN ALAMEDA
TELLS US THAT SHE HELPS PEOPLE
FOR ONE DAY AWAY FROM
HOMELESSNESS.
ANOTHER ATTORNEY TELLS US THAT.
WE CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH THE VALUE
OF SELF HELP BECAUSE IT PROVIDES
THE BEST POSSIBLE OUTCOME FOR
ALL LITIGANTS AND IT HELPS KEEPS
THE QUIRK RUNNING EFFECTIVELY.
BECAUSE IF THE PAPERWORK ISN'T
FILLED OUT PROPERLY ONLY RESULTS
IN DELAYS.
SO IN CLOSING. I KNOW ALL OF US
HERE SUPPORT AFFAIR AND
ACCESSIBLE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN OUR
RESIDENTS DESERVE THAT.
AND IT'S ONLY NATURAL THAT
CALIFORNIA BE THE LEADER IN THIS
REGARD.
ON THE NATIONAL FRONT WE HAVE
UNPRECEDENTED DISRUPTION ATTACKS
ON THE FREE PRESS
THREATS TO THE RULE OF CIVILITY
THE RULE OF LAW AND JUDICIAL
INDEPENDENCE BUT. FORTUNATELY.
OUR FOUNDERS FOCUSED MUCH ON THE
LIMITS OF POWER IN THE
CONSTITUTION WHEN THEY
CONSTRUCTED THE THREE BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT.
THE CHECKS AND BALANCES AS WELL
AS ADOPTING THE BILL OF RIGHTS
AND BUILDING A FEDERAL SYSTEM
THAT STILL RECOGNIZES. THE
RIGHTS OF STATES TO GOVERN SOME
OF THEIR OWN BUSINESS
WE KNOW THAT IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHT TO GOVERN ITS
OWN AFFAIRS IS NOW BEING
LITIGATED IN FEDERAL COURT.
SO IT'S ONLY NATURAL THAT
NATIONALLY THE LAW DAY THEME
THIS YEAR IS SEPARATION OF
POWERS. FRAMEWORK FOR FREEDOM.
OUR GOVERNOR SAID IN HIS STATE
OF THE STATE. THAT FOR
CALIFORNIA WE PERSEVERE. AND THE
BOULDER WAY IS STILL OUR WAY
FORWARD.
AND SO I ASK YOU TO HELP
TOGETHER TO STAY ON THE BOLD
PASS AND PROVIDE FOR FAIR
ACCESSIBLE JUSTICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
A REMINDER THAT MEMBERS ARE
INVITED TO PERSONALLY MEET AND
GREET THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND
ASSOCIATE JUSTICES.
AND JUDICIAL BRANCH LEADERS AT A
RECEPTION TONIGHT AT THE STANLEY
MOSK LIBRARY AND COURTS
BUILDING.
THE RECEPTION WILL BEGIN
IMMEDIATELY UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
CHIEF JUSTICE'S REMARKS WILL BE
PRINTED AS A SEPARATE APPENDIX
TO THE ASSEMBLY JOURNAL.
THE JOINT CONVENTION IS
ADJOURNED SIGNING DOT.
WE ARE BACK IN REGULAR SESSION
I'M READY ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN ME THIS TERROR HOLDEN
AND MOVES. NEWS RUBIO SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY
SECOND AT NINE AM. QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED.
THANK YOU.